I don't believe the state knows how to
run businesses I think businesses do and
that when you get the state picking
winners and deciding which technology
will be best it doesn't work what you
want is competition between businesses
to work out whether it's heat pumps or
it's hydrogen or actually it remains gas
and it's carbon capture and storage you
don't want the government siding you
want competitive businesses but
competitive business is all about
uncertainty and the people who want
certainty are the big monopolistic
incumbents who don't want to be
challenged by smaller companies who will
come up with better ideas and I hope
that answers the final question because
actually if we have competitive
businesses not being told by government
what to do we ought to be able to find
proper heating solutions for Studio
flats and urban properties it may well
be gas